so
[Music]
welcome to the 25th annual quakecon and
our first ever quakecon at home as you
can see
things are a little different this year
[Music]
don't start no barking in the byoc
many of us are still in quarantine
others are beginning to emerge
whatever the case in your local
community we knew three things
one now's probably not the best time to
gather thousands of you in one location
two we miss you all really we do
quakecon is a lot of fun for me
personally and for everyone at bethesda
in the past decade that i've been
attending the show i've gotten to know a
lot of you
we've played tabletop games together
we've hung out in the byoc
and that's what makes quakecon so
special it's about being
together playing together and
celebrating our love of games
together which brings me to our third
point this
is the 25th koicon we knew we needed to
celebrate that and to bring the quakecon
vibe to players
around the world to capture that
festival-like feel and connect with you
during three days of programming
to escape interact to play and perhaps
most important
to give back together we've always
enjoyed working with charities as part
of quakecon and this year is no
different but like the show itself we're
going global
expanding our charitable reach with
fundraising efforts to support national
and international charities we'll share
more on how you can contribute soon
but first for all the new people joining
us for this quakecon at home
i want to take a few minutes to let you
know what quakecon is all about
[Applause]
this is the event that you know and love
welcome to quakecon
[Music]
you ready to rip and tear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you can see why this show with its
unique and dedicated community
is so amazing and why this event is a
favorite for so many
year after year a quarter century of
quakecons
clearly the show had to go on but it's a
very different kind of show
we've taken one of the biggest lan
parties in the world and turned it
virtual
and we've gone global not just in reach
but in participation
with streams scheduled from our teams
around the world
but there's one thing even our
volunteers don't all agree on
folks have we come to a decision on this
yet i'm so happy
to be ready to plan koicon's
25th anniversary are you ready
it's now the 25th anniversary that's
next year
25 what it's the anniversary
we're excited no it's the 25th
you don't have the anniversary on the
first one you have the anniversary on
the second one
started 1996. you're off by one
i'm pretty sure
settled clear as mud participating in
that great debate
some of the volunteers who have helped
build this show for the last quarter
century
so i want to take a moment to once again
thank the quakecon volunteers
who contributed to this year's show as
well helping shape it with their ideas
and ongoing support and as a special
tribute to the volunteers
and to the show itself i vow that i will
live the full quakecon experience at
home
for the next three days i will only eat
food served from a truck
i've got all my favorite t-shirts from
previous quake cons lined up and ready
to wear
and i'll be popping into the streams to
chat with all of you throughout the show
but before we jump into the programming
let's take a moment to update you
on a few of our games there we go
it's recording check check
welcome everyone to the temporary
headquarters of zenimax online studios
you know quakecon is one of my favorite
shows of the year
in fact it's community based just like
elder scrolls online
some of my favorite eso panel
discussions have come at quakecon
where we get more time to go in depth
about game features and systems
we're really sorry we can't be there in
person this year but i'm glad i get this
moment to share with you even if it's
just on video
this year eso is taking you on a
year-long journey through the
darkhearted skyrim
we recently launched the graymore
chapter and now record numbers of you
are adventuring across the iconic
landscape and discovering the sinister
secrets
lurking beneath skyrim and we've got
more to come
the stonethorne dlc is launching later
this month and to celebrate
i've got the world premiere of an
all-new gameplay trailer for you
check it out now
[Music]
never in the history of house raven
watch
have we witnessed such a depraved
vampire conspiracy
the resurrection of the grey host would
mean the end of skyrim
perhaps even tamriel itself
[Music]
and if you haven't yet played eso now is
the perfect time to start it's free to
play on all platforms for the next two
weeks
so come and join the over 16 million of
you
that have adventured across this amazing
fantasy virtual world
we can't wait to see in tamriel thank
you everyone
awesome now let's catch up with jeff
gardner at bethesda game studios i mean
he's at home but you know what i mean
this is my new puppy moki
so we were at quakecon about to do a big
panel when you first walk in that
magnificent hotel and it's like a
adult wonderland and then you go back
into the room with everyone's
rigs and their computers and you see
everything that's going on there
and the excitement it's amazing and i
actually really wanted to bring my son
this year but
[Music]
with the release of wastelanders this
year we brought npcs back into the game
our last patch just recently added in a
new looking for root feature
and a challenge board a legendary run
which is free to all players
to allow you to do daily challenges to
get unlocked
items and weapons the game is super fun
we're continuing to tweak it reading
community feedback changing things
it's going to be an ever evolving game
we want it to evolve with the fans
and we're not done yet soon we'll have
even more coming
including one wasteland you'll be able
to go anywhere with anyone and take on
challenges regardless of your level
we'll also be adding a new way to
explore and experience our dungeons with
daily ops plus the season 2 challenge
pass
or race and remember all our updates are
free to anyone who owns fallout 76
so keep playing and keep sharing your
feedback with us
and if you haven't visited appalachia we
welcome you to join us and see how much
fun you can have
rebuilding the wasteland thank you
thanks jeff now let's check in with
marty and hugo for the latest
on do maternal
the hair has gotten very long uh it's
feeling a little 80s right now i'm
i figured i'd try to use the the marty
and i are a team and
and marty's the executive producer he's
the jerry bruckheimer
of of this equation so to see him with
longer hair it's a little weird but
i'm digging marty's hair personally i
think it looks good if you've ever been
to quakecon in dallas
you know just how much this event means
to all of us at id
for the past 25 years we've camped out
playing games with you in the byoc
offered sneak peeks and demos of our
latest work
or shared our design stories in panels
and presentations
and you've always been there for us
thank you so much
for helping create some of the best
moments and memories in the history
of our studio and our games it's been
amazing to see your response to do
maternal
i mean i get so much from watching you
play on twitch and youtube
from the ultra nightmare runs to the new
players going through the campaign for
the first time
or the incredible displays of skill from
our top battle mode players
on friday night fights through it all
we're seeing you learn
get better and master the experience and
that's what do maternal
is all about so no matter who you are or
how you play the game
know that your passion and appreciation
continues to motivate all of us
in everything we do
there is only one dominant life form in
this universe
the slayer's time is now
it's also amazing the amount of carnage
and destruction you've managed to create
in the short time since launch like how
about the fact
that you've killed more than 12 billion
demons 2.9 billion of those
were by glory kills alone and 1 billion
with everyone's favorite
the super shotgun or how about the 607
million nuked demons by the bfg i mean
all together
that's a lot of dead demons and who
doesn't want more toys
you've managed to collect 41 million of
those things
and amass 86 million one-ups and by the
way because i get asked this all the
time
yes the team at bethesda is working hard
at getting
the real toys made for you we really
have enjoyed seeing how much fun you're
having with the game
but we've also been hard at work on
updates and new content from new visual
rendering modes
and a totally new battle mode map to
empower
demons and multiplayer latency
improvements
doom eternal gets bigger and better with
every update
despite the challenges of working from
home we're still
looking forward to releasing invasion
and more campaign master levels
as well as new maps playable demons and
a competitive ranked mode for battle
mode
our highest priority however has been on
what you told us
you want most so what better place
to share a short tease of our first
campaign expansion
you are here to restore order to my
world
with the demons in control you
understand the threat they posed
to all my creations
yes the ancient gods part one picks up
after the events of do maternal
hell was ripped heaven was torn and the
slayer's legend grew
your rampage of destruction saved
humanity from extinction
but it it came at a cost now there's an
imbalance in power in the heavens
and the true ruler of the doom universe
must rise to set things right
it's all very cool very comic book yes
thank you again
from everyone at id software and
hopefully
we'll be seeing you all in person again
next year
next up let's head to tokyo the home of
ghost wire tokyo
and visit with the incomparable shinji
mikami
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
speaking of petting dogs be sure to
donate to one of our favorite quakecon
charities dallas pets alive
for some really cool t-shirts more on
that later now let's see what's up with
our friends at arcane leone
dinga and sebastian sorry i just bumped
the camera
okay
such an honor to be following shinji
mikami but we also honored to be
addressing all of you at quakkon
like our friends at tango arcane
released our first gameplay trailer for
desloop
in june at the ps5 future of gaming
events
we were energized by all your
heartwarming positive feedback
let's recap what we can share with you
about our game
we introduced you to colt a soldier
trapped in a time loop on the island of
black reef
hunted by everyone forced to relieve the
same day over and over again
in order to free himself from this cycle
of madness
colt must kill eight powerful
visionaries
before midnight but they are scattered
across the island
and their schedules don't seem to line
up in a way that would make it possible
and this is where you come in you get to
decide how to solve what we like to call
a reverse murder puzzle
figure out your target's plans decide
how and when to exploit them
how to go loud or to go stealthy what
passes to take
and each time the cycle resets you'll be
stronger
wiser closer to solving the mysteries of
the island
and finally breaking the loop
but watch your back juliana one of your
targets
is a rival assassin our sole purpose is
to sell chaos in your carefully led
plans
sounds exciting well if you feel like
being the villain you can step in her
sneakers
and control her in another's player's
game to create
memorable duels and squamishes whether
you decide to break the loop
as cult in the campaign or become a
villain in other players games as
juliana
you'll choose your tactics your weapons
your abilities
and tailor your own approach and play
style now
let's talk about the world and more
precisely
black reef as the island itself is a
character
and everything you see contributes to
the game and the story in desloop
first take a northern island with a
mysterious fishing town
completely isolated from the world spice
that up with 60s inspired per part
and use it as a backdrop for a wild
crazy
never-ending party then you'll get an
idea of the world that arcane leon's our
team is building for you
and because this desloop is supercharged
by the power of the playstation 5
you can expect a feast for the senses
smooth frame rate
4k and hdr support and we are also
utilizing dual sense controller features
like haptic feedback and adaptive
triggers to immerse you
in first person shooter gameplay i'm
sure you're eager to see more of death
loop
don't worry we'll be satisfying your
curiosity
very soon ali auroiah
and thanks to all our studios who remain
dedicated to delivering amazing
experiences that you'll play and love
for years to come a few months ago we
started our celebration of 20 years of
arcane
here's a quick look at what makes arcane
studios so special
nothing is an accident everything is in
motion
you up for one last job billy
[Music]
like every year we're running all kinds
of deals and specials
including the arcane bundle which
features so many of the studio's biggest
hits
throughout the week you can pick up many
of our games for 50
off some as low as 80 off and we're also
putting eso's newest chapter
graymore on sale for the very first time
plus
you can play eso for free for the next
two weeks on the platform of your choice
head to bethesda.net for all the details
including the quakecon pc bundle
and the worldwide launch of the doom
slayers digital edition
and that about wraps it up for me before
i go a quick shout out to our sponsors
they'll be giving away some great prizes
throughout the show
also a reminder we're supporting a range
of charities throughout the stream
and you can donate directly to the same
charities we're supporting
these include unicef direct relief naacp
legal defense and educational fund
and the trevor project and of course
we're continuing to work with one local
texas based charity that's near and dear
to my heart dallas pets alive
don't miss out on getting one or both of
these awesome t-shirts
we've got a full schedule on
bethesda.net along with all the news
we've revealed
and information on how to participate in
our charitable initiatives
and be sure to join us in our quakecon
discord channel to connect with the
community
it's almost like being right there in
the byoc and now it's time to sit back
relax and enjoy the next three days of
streaming
we're honored that you've made quakecon
your home stay safe
stay healthy and have fun
[Music]
all right i'm going to count down the
problem here three two
one
oh [ __ ] touch the button hi folks
[Music]
gonna have to wait for my phone to stop
hold on nicole
this loop is supercharged it's literally
the super challenge
really excited about uh ancient gods uh
part is that what it is
[Music]
that's what make quick god
god bless america the sound guy is like
dude what the f
[Music]
with my fallout mug right here and am i
am i uh
look i got i'm easy like
[Music]
giant ass bug i could be like this do
not put that on camera
you